alors faut-il repenser l'avenir des
militaires français au mali qu'est ce
qui a mené à cette expulsion de
l'ambassadeur français de bamako place
maintenant au décryptage
avec nous pourrons parler régis le
sommier grand reporter ert france qui
connaît très bien le malaise de mali
pour y avoir fait plusieurs reportages
bonsoir régis à nos côtés également bam
s'est brouillée 6 et parlementaires
membres du conseil national de
transition bonsoir et merci d'être avec
nous également bakary traoré consultant
et spécialiste du sel bonsoir bakary
traoré alors comme ça au gouvernement de
transition la france et les européens se
trouve un petit peu au pied du mur au
dos au mur je dirais régie c'est l'heure
de vérité un tournant dans cette
coopération mais clairement il ya une
forme de prêts de un tournant oui on est
à huit ans de l'opération serval puis
l'opération barkan qui a suivi il y à
une remise en cause de la part d'un pays
le mali may avançant qu'ils ont décidé
des soubresauts burkina faso qui vient
de subir un coup d'état aussi et une
remise en cause en fait globalement de
7,2 cette présence est peut-être aussi
la pertinence finalement de cette
opération barkan où va-t-elle la france
on sait c'est déjà repli retirer du nord
du mali elle est concentrée maintenant
en dans une zone qui va de commandes du
gourma au liptako avec en gros la base
de gao donc c'est vraiment le
la zone des trois frontières
la france a quitté ses bases de kidal de
tessalit tu de tombouctou pour se
replier donc il ya déjà une situation de
retrait de la france et puis il y à
cette situation de comment gérer deux
guerres diplomatiques entre le
gouvernement de transition et le
gouvernement français qui s'est
exacerbée on sent bien que
d'un côté les maliens andy avait dit par
la voix de leur premier ministre qu'ils
avaient l'impression d'être abandonné en
plein vol ans avait été le terme leu leu
leu des termes utilisés comment marcher
hauguel maïga à l'onu et depuis cette
situation n'a fait qu'empirer avec un
dialogue de sourds et puis au milieu de
tout ça
cette discussion avec donc la smp wagner
qui est venu un petit peut dynamiter les
choses en tout cas les les durcir je
dirais également aussi la mise au mavi
du la mise à l'écart du mali de par la
cedeao qui a accès à accélérer les
choses et tout ça aujourd'hui arrive on
arrive à la situation où le mali décide
d'expulser l'ambassadeur de france et là
on n'est pas en a pas c'est quand même
un cap on va évidemment parler un de ces
problématiques notamment jean yves le
drian s'est s'exprimé à l'assemblée
nationale cet après midi c'est mme
bouillé si c'est justement sur
l'expulsion de cet ambassadeur français
comment vous vous vous l'expliquer parce
que c'est assez grave en d'expulsion 1
un ambassadeur c'est très symbolique
comment justifier comment expliquer en
effet compte tenu des rapports entre la
france les rapports historiques entre la
france et le mali je pense que c'est une
première mais aussi je rappelle il y a à
peu près deux ans la france avait
demandé au mal et de rappeler
l'ambassadeur du mali en france bien
quand même dans dans le sens inverse
c'était du jamais vu effectivement je
dirais quelque part je suis solidaire de
mon gouvernement pas parce que je suis
malien parce que je suis parlementaire
de cette transition mais à un moment
donné il est encore respecte ces peuples
africains il est temps qu'on respecte
les maliens les propos du ministre de
monsieur le ministre le drian ou de
maltais et moi d'en parler depuis
quelques jours à un moment donné il
était temps que on leur montre aussi que
nous existons nous sommes un peuple
souverain même si nous sommes en
difficulté mais aussi nous avons nous
avons fait appel à la france en janvier
2013 à travers l'opération serval pour
nous aider mais je rappelle aussi que
même s'il suite à l'engagement de la
france contre kadhafi et par ricochet le
mali est tombée aujourd'hui c'est le
burkina le niger
voire même peut-être la mauritanie
demain bakary traoré c'est
vrai que les lectures habituelles les
voix qu'on entend en france notamment
dans les médias on parle beaucoup je
regardais ce matin les chaînes
d'information la france humiliée et ses
pendants interrogations se poser la
question est aujourd'hui un média sur ce
plateau nous dit eh bien voilà on s'est
senti humilié et cette décision
d'expulsion c'est aussi le résultat de 2
comment la france a traité le le mali
oui tout à fait je confirme c'est qu'il
vienne et du le pain le matin de 6 et
c'est le sentiment général de haut
niveau du mali si ces déclarations de
ses dirigeants
la tradition
qualifié d'illégitime d'irresponsables
je pense que tous la calade débat au
niveau diplomatique entre bâle et la
france étaient parties de la déclaration
du président macro multi juin 2021 la
combine a lancé dessus et dans la fin
des bars canada coopération mais son
réaménagement au niveau 2 au niveau des
shows de l'e3 frontières et donc
les choses sont laissés à l'écran mais
de l'autre je dis on constate que la
france n'a pas tenu compte des trophées
majeurs ou dans leur était de bretagne
n'a pas tenu compte du fait que c'est
bien
le mali dans cet état d'une situation où
le plan dans deux le retrait du mali n'a
pas tenu compte 16 virages plus loin du
gouvernement
c'est à dire que le gouvernement
précédent
et b qui a négocié des choses qui à nous
des rapports avec la france et bien ce
gouvernement a été renversé par le
colonel lionel
astier greta et bien cet état des faits
c'est à dire juste changement de
gouvernement d'un parti tenue rose
toutefois au niveau du plan d'eau était
de le débarquer deux faits majeurs à mon
avis c'est le discours que le pénis le
choc à la manga étudie la terminer
nations unies en septembre dernier où il
a
le monde ici synthèse abandonné en plein
vol parce que suite à cette déclaration
du maquereau dépassera plus les intérêts
la france a choisi est bien dorée tirée
par quatre points stratégiques de la
capitale notamment été solides notamment
et aux banques tout est trop cher majeur
aussi et bien c'est cette
diversification des partenaires hier que
le manuel initiée
diversification des partenariats qui a
abouti à l'arrivée de l'état russe
d'anciennes contre de coopération ou
bien cette population et bien tout ce
qui m'attire à l'état malien
la rue emmanuel et jusque là prononcer
des deux années c'est à dire l'appui
aérien et les renseignements et
d'ailleurs
cette coordination avec l'armée russe on
le constate mme aubry a atteint
deportivo des fruits notamment le
démantèlement des différends par
terroristes à travers le centre mais
aussi à travers de nos vues de m je
pense que c'était un territoire majeur
n'ont pas été tenus contre le dispositif
de retraite des postes stratégiques dans
la norme ansi bien sûr il ya eu des
conséquences majeures la première
conséquence bien sûr c'est le fait que
l'état malien a témoigné finalement une
des légumes les accords de défense avec
avec la france s'étaient pardonnez-moi
vaccarès traoré parce que c'est vrai que
comme vous êtes 3par donnant sur le
plateau on va essayer de voir tout ça un
parent alors il ya eu évidemment en
france des réactions a notamment à
l'assemblée nationale aujourd'hui
puisque le possible retrait un militaire
français du mali a été abordée on
rappelle que gabriel attal a rappelé
aujourd'hui que paris progressivement
réduisez la voilure et qu'on allait
continuer à le faire a rappelé le porte
parole du gouvernement plusieurs
réactions des députés aujourd'hui l'élu
communiste par exemple jean paul lecoq
malgré le courage de nos soldats aux
mails l'armée française a échoué
appelant donc à ce retrait des français
régis le sommier est ce que c'est aussi
simple que ça c'est un échec cuisant et
il faudrait pas retenir aujourd'hui
selon tout cas ce député la question est
dans l'air la difficulté en fait la
france grand contre au mali
peut-être comparé à mon sens à la
difficulté que les américains ont
rencontré en afghanistan d'un
déploiement qui finalement n'a pas tu
perds au départ répond à un impératif de
sécurité et de protection je rappelle
que les colonnes donc djihadistes alliés
comment des miliciens touareg venus de
libye ont déferlé sur le mali et que la
finalité de l'opération serval justement
ça a été d'arrêter de les empêcher
justement d'aller plus vers le sud
7 comme les américains eux étaient
intervenus en afghanistan pour en
chasser al qaïda et les éléments
terroristes qui avaient frappé
l'occident là pour le coup s'agissait de
deux commandes de venir en aide au mali
dans un premier temps moi je me souviens
à l'époque
le discours de tombes tous deux de
commandes de françois hollande l'ovation
le fait que les soldats français canton
patrouiller dans les villes les enfants
mais à court et vers l'est vers les
véhicules blindés quand je suis passé au
mali dans la zone de ménaka notamment en
avril dernier c'était plus du tout le
cas il y avait plus du tout cet
enthousiasme est plus du tout s'est tu
sais tu comment gérer cette cette
adhésion de la population le sentais
bien alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé la
mission marque anna et et je dirai
comment élargi la france et ses alliés
la coalition dû superviser finalement
est un territoire qui partait de la
mauritanie pour arriver au tchad avec
4500 soldats 10000 membres de la minus
massy on a tous les 1000 tchadien ça
fait très peu pour une zone qui est
immense et le général michon a récemment
avoué était interviewé par la lfp au
moment où j'étais au mali en
fin décembre il disait qu' il y avait ce
sentiment d'échec de sécurisation de
pacification du sel il l'admettait parce
que la tâche était considérable le
problème principal me semble-t-il n'est
pas le problème de l'efficacité des
français ou l'efficacité de la coalition
l'a vu récemment au burkina avec le raid
qui s'est opérée qui a détruit environ
60 djihadistes ya on est capable
d'intervenir et on a eu des résultats
mais le problème c'est que la présence
française ne s'est pas transformé en
parallèle avec un retour des services
publics dans certaines zones au mali
avec un retour de l'armée malienne dans
certaines je dirais que une partie du
territoire et est tombé d'une certaine
façon en jachère ce qui est terrible
c'est que dans le même temps que la
france était présente et qu'elle
continuait à développer cette action
contre les groupes armés très terroriste
est bien dans le même temps le mal le
mali partait à vau de l'eau je pense
qu'une explique une des explications
parce que quand on parle le colonel
putschiste ils sont pas arriver comme ça
et je voudrais mon but n'est pas de les
défendre nécessairement mais quand on
voit le pédigré du colonel a thing aux
états c'est pas quelqu'un qui est là
pour s'enrichir c'est pas quelqu'un
c'est quelqu'un qui était chef des
forces spéciales malienne qui a kiss est
confronté justement au terrorisme sur le
terrain et c'est pas quelqu'un c'est
quelqu'un de plutôt intègre et
aujourd'hui on les voit comme des
militaires sécessionniste mais il faut
voir aussi que le pouvoir malien qui
l'aura précis qui a précédé étaient
aussi s'est avéré incapable justement de
rétablir 7,7 comment dire cette
administration est en tout cas de
contrôler ce pays qui s'est effritée
dans le même temps la france est en
était là et là et le hélas là comment la
présence française sait c'est comment
dire s'est prolongée peut-être trop
puisque c'est systématique je prendrai
l'exemple à des fins des américains en
afghanistan c'est que au final la
population commence à considérer la
france comme une puissance occupante et
non plus comme une puissance qui vient
aider le pays est évidemment le néo
colonialisme et ses pouvoirs que le mali
avec une transition dans les années 60
il a obtenu son indépendance il était
marxiste léniniste ila été là il s'est
opposé mais voilà il ya une tradition
aussi de sao ma vigne
au colonialisme est apparu à mon sens
aussi à cause beaucoup de maliens qui
recense que vient de décrire régis le
sommier ses racines rock si ça vient de
là la part d'un grand reporter français
c'est pas un malien qui le dit il vient
de prouver ce qu'il a vu que lui régis
le sommier vient de dire clairement ce
qu'il a vu lui sur le terrain
l'évolution de 2013 à 2021 ou 2022
effectivement un moment donné quand vous
êtes sûrs dans un pays étranger et avec
des résultats il réussit faut pas tout
remettre en cause à cause de quelques
envolées lyriques de part et d'autre il
ya eu et des quelques réussites est ce
que je voudrais continuer de la suite de
régis le sommier ce que le premier
ministre sur quel manga a dit à la
tribune des nations unies moi je le
prends comme un cri de coeur
jamais on n'a jamais demandé le départ
de la france entre les autorités
maliennes site mais aussi ci et là
quelques moyens le disent nous on n'a
jamais vraiment l'état malien n'a jamais
demandé le départ de la france c'est la
france qui a décidé vous venez de le
rappeler mais se dire vrai la talent ce
matin sur france inter le disait
clairement qu'il faut ils vont réduire
la voilure mais un pays quand même ça
sous-entend
de l'anticipation vous voulez partir ou
veut réduire la voilure non on ne peut
pas rester les bras ballants sachant que
comme je le disais tantôt cette guerre
nous est tombé dessus depuis la libye
aujourd'hui on sait ce qui s'est passé
on a un homme d'expérience registre de
dire qui est le cas à 6,8 à aujourd'hui
qu'on aime qu'on n'aime pas qu'on aime
les militaires ou pas il ya un résultat
probant qui est là depuis six mois il ya
des résultats sur le terrain on récupère
des centaines des villes de villages et
des dialyses qui sera battu au
quotidiennement aujourd'hui
non aujourd'hui il ya un rêve et à kehl
à cette montée populaire autour des cinq
colonels ci n'est pas s'il n'est pas
quelque chose d'anodin habituellement
dans ces zones là on paie les gens pour
voter pour quelqu'un est aujourd'hui pas
plus tard que le 14 janvier et une
démonstration de force où le public nous
le peuple moyen est sorti dans toutes
les grandes villes ont la vie ne serait
ce qu'à brûlant que je pense qu'il y
avait au moins vingt mille personnes et
a pas de ceux qui parlent de sang mme
anti-français ya pas de sentiment anti
français pour ceux qui connaissent vos
mac os le boulevard de l'indépendance la
place de l'indépendance la ville centre
culturel français personne n'a été
touché vous prenez le drapeau français
là bas donc il n'y a pas de sentiment
anti-français fille juste peut-être qu'à
un moment donné les plus hautes
autorités françaises devraient commencer
à respecter ces peuples africains et de
par là moi je vois par exemple je dirais
aujourd'hui juste pour terminer je suis
un peu jaloux de la solidarité
européenne savez tous les pays européens
soutien de la france et de l'autre côté
vous avez tous les pays africains qui
sanctionne le mali et la guinée voilà un
petit peu vous avez 27 pays européens il
n'y a pas de frontières nous pays pauvre
enclavé on saute aux sanctions et
aujourd'hui on le voit la côte d'ivoire
on voit apparemment cet après midi et
quelques coups de feu en guinée-bissau
il ya une semaine le coup d'état était
consommée au burkina faso où allons nous
il est temps aujourd'hui d'évaluer
barkan de cerval abarkan est aujourd'hui
que nous allons aussi sont en train de
monter en puissance et des populations
le ressentent ça c'est palpable en tout
cas le ministre français des affaires
étrangères aujourd'hui jean yves le
drian interpellé par l'opposition
notamment par le député jean lassalle en
qui parlait dans un camouflé historique
à potelle isolement du mali et fustigé
d'ailleurs les seuls partenaires dont
vous parliez tout à l'heure les
mercenaires je cite un selon lui de
wagner écouter le ministre des affaires
étrangères français le combat contre le
terrorisme
monsieur le député lassalle se
poursuivra et se poursuivra au sahel il
se poursuivra aussi avec l'accord des
autres pays de la région et je vous ira
aussi en soutien des pays du golfe de
guinée qui aujourd'hui voit la porosité
des groupes des frontières permettent
aux groupes terroristes de pénétrer dans
le nord de ce territoire donc notre
volonté est intacte ce n'est pas un
événement du à l'irresponsabilité je
réitère mes mots du ahly légitimité d'un
gouvernement de coup d'état qui va nous
faire enrayer notre lutte contre le
terrorisme le mali c'est une question
propre au mali et je dirais que l'
isolement du mal y est elle aujourd'hui
qu'il n'a que seul partenaire les
mercenaires de wagner c'est tout ce
qu'il trouve le seul partenaire aux jo
de l'huma liszt et wagner tous les
autres veulent que le mali retrouve la
démocratie et le combat contre le
terrorisme j'en ai donné drian cet après
midi à l'assemblée nationale et sur la
présence présumée de wagner je vous
propose d'écouter
la version russe tout même dimitri
bodianski représentant permanent de la
fédération de russie auprès de l'onu
quant à l'implication présumée du groupe
wagner une fois de plus cela n'a rien à
voir avec les responsables russes le
groupe n'est pas soutenu par l'état
inquiètent ce dernier s'il est sur le
marché alors c'est à chaque pays de
décider s'il va coopérer avec cette
entreprise ou non le mali n'est pas une
exception dans ce cas je ne vois aucune
raison pour laquelle le gouvernement
malien ne peut pas prendre la décision
souveraine de s'engager avec cette
compagnie militaire ou avec une autre
compagnie militaire de ce genre dans
notre pays je veux dire
il y aussi une coopération
gouvernementale entre la russie et le
mali mais c'est une autre histoire
les deux versions voyez si ces gens
voyaient réagir aux propos de jean yves
le drian non à dire que le mali est
isolée par l'ensemble la communauté
internationale ça ce n'est pas vrai
aujourd'hui je le disais on travaille
avec la russie le docteur usuel de
confirmer enfin qu'on parle de wagner ou
de aujourd'hui jusqu'à preuve du
contraire moi je suis parlementaire dans
le contrôle de l'action gouvernementale
on n'a pas de preuves nous qui à wagner
mercier quand même que l'état russe car
company le manier et d'ailleurs si ces
sont des relations historiques ceux des
pires le temps de nos pères de
l'indépendance c'est n'est pas forcément
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui oui on se tourne
vers d'autres partenaires de la france à
des conventions multilatérales avec deux
pays pas forcément avec les européens et
les américains pourquoi on empêcherait
le home alliés d'avoir d'autres
partenaires
qui sont autres que la france ou des
européens bakary traoré oui vouliez
réagir
oui tout à fait parce que
ses propos auraient été les de monsieur
les clients
chanteuse anglaise adele d'irrespect et
des discours et des disques au début du
conflit et bien une diplomatie ce sont
les signes ces droites etc de l'échec
d'une diplomatie
les propos discourtois et les invectives
du pense que ce sont des sites
informatiques d'une diplomatie et c'est
tout à fait regrettable c'est tout à
fait des prêts table d'autant plus
qu'aujourd'hui
le mali a envoyé une demande
le premier après l'étude la connaissance
je pense que ça pourrait être l'occasion
de
voir la position sa position et de
décéder d'un colloque on les croise ses
complices et qui a lui dû faire dans cet
accord de défense et qui tient botte
bien sur la coque de respect de la
constitution du mali sa souveraineté
ce qui est un montant des souliers en
arménie dans cette crise diplomatique
entre le mali et la france c'est que ça
fait dix ans que le mali et dans ce
bourbier le manière qu'ils appellent la
communauté internationale à gauche et
malheureusement ce que le maniement des
citadelles après des liens et des
renseignements pour doper les hauts
plateaux militaires n'ont pas été au
rendez-vous et si bien aujourd'hui et
bien même si bien la france se les
tribus mani et celui de croire dans
d'autres parties du sahel je pense pas
qu'un peu eh bien la france ne tient pas
compte du fait que c est abordé à des
troubles nous sommes mais ne pas besoin
de tout commentaire mais on les aime
beaucoup plus
haut niveau de l'enzyme édition niveau
des moyens pour neutraliser le diariste
et bien si la france ne persiste pas
lâche pas et ne s'engage pas dans cette
moi je pense que en france par boîte
l'échec et par rapport à sa gestion de
la caisse dans les ca n est il ya une
autre coin il inventa compostière mon
avis c'est que ça fait dix ans qu'on ne
crie vie cette église pour les jours
presque toutes les semaines c'est des
godillots
de ne sont pas maliens qui sont ils sont
combien ce qu'ils s'entendent en
souffrent si des lieux aujourd'hui
l'armée a finalement c'est hier soir ça
fait une semaine que l'armée a pu
démonter les bases terroristes dans le
nord et dessins tribus mani avec la
neutralisation des peines d'une
trentaine d'ong du pianiste et nativité
l'émirat justice tout cela démontre
vraiment des mots qui en dix ans
d'efforts
avec
la russie
n'est pas isolé qui est le droit
effectivement d'avoir les partenaires
qu'ils valent non alors il ya une wii et
le mali n'est pas forcément isolé
peut-être pas autant que en tout cas c
est clair qu'il ya eu quand même une une
fermeture des frontières et puis la
rupture d'un certain nombre d' échanges
entre le mali et les principaux pays que
limitrophes en revanche sur ladite
déclaration de commande de jean yves le
drian moi je voudrais revenir sur le
caractère alors effectivement illégitime
illégale parce que le gouvernement ait
putschistes et que le gouvernement
s'appelle le gouvernement de transition
moi je constate que la qualification de
gouvernement de transition n'est pas
propre au mali elle existe aussi au
tchad et qu'on la voit pas vraiment
remise au tchad où comme par hasard
c'est le partenaire le pilier central de
barkan et c'est là qu'ont été rapatriés
nos forces spéciales d'ailleurs et et
une partie de l'état-major donc on
demande pas autant aux tchadiens de
procéder à une transition démographe
démocratique le gouvernement burkinabè
depuis limoux semaine est aussi un
gouvernement de transition et le
gouvernement de guinée est aussi un
gouvernement de transition donc si vous
voulez ce ces putschs sur cette
multiplication des pushs commence un
petit peu à faire gérer boule de neige
en afrique il ya une là il ya quelque
chose sur lequel il faut s'interroger
parce que on peut pas voilà comment
stigmatiser uniquement le mali en lui
disant conduisait des élections
conduisait des élections le problème du
mali c'est une question à mon sens alors
il ya tout un tas de composantes et des
affaires politiques internement au mali
qui demanderait beaucoup de
développement et que un parlementaire
est plutôt a même plus à même que moi de
d'expliquer en revanche sur la question
sécuritaire moi je voudrais revenir là
dessus il ya un vrai problème pour tenir
des élections au mali aujourd'hui on est
dans une dans une situation il faut
regarder les choses moi les dernières
opérations j'ai suivi avec barkan et
notamment je parle de la une opération
et une légion étrangère en 2020 toute la
zone en fait entre même ménaka et la
frontière c'est une zone en fait la
plupart de la part des populations ont
disparu il reste incertain il ya une
guerre ethnique énorme là c'est le
territoire de ligier s comment voulez
vous conduire des élections au milieu du
territoire de logis est ce qu'au milieu
du territoire d'aqmi tant que l'aude les
autorités maliennes n'auront pas repris
contact soir avec des tractations parce
que ces tractations existe avec ces
groupes y compris des groupes qui sont
aujourd'hui des clac déclarait groupe
armé terroriste parce que il faut qu'ils
aient un dialogue il faut que refaire
revenir cc by cc comment ces groupes est
en tout cas tenté d'apporter une
solution pour que le mali reprennent
contrôle de son territoire et pour le
moment ce n'est pas le cas donc
qu'est-ce que ça va être ça va être des
élections où ben oui on va dire voilà
encore une fois les notes sont achetés
et beaucoup y ait beaucoup de
ressentiment là dessus par rapport aux
précédentes élections déjà donc voilà
les conditions aujourd'hui ne sont pas
réunies et voilà et la junte au pouvoir
en effet n'est pas arrivé au pouvoir par
hasard elle n'est pas arrivé est arrivé
parce que avant globalement le comment
toute la période
ibrahim keita a quand même été une
période de désagrégation totale du mali
avec une corruption extrême donc voilà
il ya aussi une explication interne au
mali et qui aujourd'hui explique ce qui
se passe merci beaucoup ont été sonnées
bas est mouillé cissé bakary traoré
d'avoir été avec nous pour ce décryptage